hey guys I'm Jess McDonald and it is
Friday which means you're tuned into my
top five sure so let's give you the
rundown on five of the biggest things
that happened in gaming this week
first up titanfall on Xbox 360 is set to
disappoint even more impatient gamers as
it's just been hit with another delay
the game is now being pushed back to
extra weights to April 8 in the US after
already suffering a delay from its
original release date alongside the
launch of the PC and Xbox one versions
EA has said that the game is looking
good but they can on giving the dev
BluePoint a little more time to refine
and make sure the quality is top-notch
a speedrunner has struck concern into
the hearts of Metal Gear fans this week
as he spiked headlines saying that
ground zeroes can be completed in ten
minutes could is the operative word
there because it's the same as studying
the speedrun world record for any old
game the players skipped all the
cutscenes which you can appropriately
assume a twenty minutes apiece and brace
his way to the end of the game knowing
full well where he was going so ground
zeroes is short but not that short if
you want to see the spoiler of expedia
ed over to eurogamer's we've told you a
couple of times now that EA is back in
the running for worst company in America
but the way that this one is unraveled
is pretty interesting
if PA wins this it will be their third
consecutive title as worst company and
you guys seem pretty divided into the
cats of EA sucks let's get them the
hat-trick and EA is certainly not as bad
as some of the other companies on this
lift said companies include Abercrombie
& Fitch Microsoft SeaWorld and plenty
more examples of company douchebaggery
Sony has made Canada sad this week by
upping the price of the ps4 and some of
its games in the country the console is
getting a $50 price bump while games
like infamous second son and MLB 14 the
show are set to release at 70 bucks
that's a chunk less than us poor
Australians are forking out but still
completely uncool as for their vague
reasoning Sony have cited that it is in
response to changes in the market
environment
sorry Canada just so you know it's still
550 bucks over here it's really a
complaining out lastly it's all about
the ps4 virtual reality and project
Morpheus the cliffnotes of the reveal at
GDC
are that the current prototype of the
headset works with a 1080p display
90-plus degree field of view and 3d
audio it's currently running a version
of Square Enix as thief eval Curie and
two games called the deep and the castle
on pricing and a potential release date
Shuhei Yoshida said it won't cost you a
thousand bucks and won't be hitting the
market this year but apart from that has
been fairly bait let me know which came
out of all the games you would want to
play using virtual reality either in the
comments section down below or you can
do so on my Twitter where I'm at just
like Donal this week on site you do well
to check out my gist episode on why the
3d s is better than the ps4 or Xbox one
watch cam instead of you being kingly in
Skyrim and catch Danny speaking Gaelic
in the points and that is all the news
that I've got through this way to be
sure to check back with me again on
Monday but till then I hope you have a
great weekend